tu dois aider mon ami ton impuissance vampirique a
commencé quand tu as tué l'amour
de ta vie au revoir Mary je ne suis PAS
ce que tu appellerais un plaisir si maudit
avec quelqu'un
ouais avec Kappa Omicron Kappa oh ce
sont les plus grands saints Oh professeur Ghrist
oui qui est  elle est comme Mary, elle est
votre vampire par agra UK, elle est devenue
sportive en vampire, elle est hors de contrôle
, je dois arrêter, laissez-nous vous aider
qui veut être un vampire,
pourquoi ne pouvez-vous pas vous battre par vous-même
parce que je suis des vampires impuissants  se battre avec leur
saucisse
es-tu prêt à faire ça il y a des
filles vampires dans cette maison elles
vont nous tuer
je suis gay haha